tell me uh about the day you guys went
to no jumper with American cholo because
there's a lot a lot of guys a lot of the
homies came with you yeah yeah uh yeah
but that's the thing like look man and I
know you have a great relationship with
A.D yeah and um you guys obviously have
music together and you guys have a a a a
strong bond but uh just what was the um
the thought process of just bringing a
bunch of bunch of fools with you because
it was a lot of people yeah yeah we went
we went deep as [ __ ] um and honestly bro
it was this dog like like
in our community our elders are are very
much respected you know what I'm saying
I would hope that in every Community but
in ours of course in ours though we we
do like really listen I have a Mexican
wife yeah and a Mexican baby mama yeah
yeah so you know 100 yeah so so when Gil
was getting attacked I saw it you know
what I'm saying I saw it and I knew the
history behind it so I could stand
behind him you know what I'm saying you
knew the context yeah I knew I knew the
context exactly how it was right so um
he calls me and I could hear it in his
voice that he's looking for some kind of
like like I don't want to say help
because I don't want to make him sound
weak but he was looking for a friend dog
you feel I'm saying somebody to stand
beside him that that had a validity out
here that can really speak up on [ __ ]
that's been there done that so um I
didn't even let him ask me I just told
him like Hey bro you want me to go with
you and he was like yeah you know so
then I saw it as an opportunity to bring
a lot of homies together like what
people don't understand bro is like yeah
we came deep and and there was all
homies but I had a lot of rival gangs
there that aren't supposed to be
together so you kind of brought some
people hell yeah like the homies came
together without question nobody nobody
ever oh so before I get to that yeah so
you know I asked them like you want me
to go with you he's like yeah if you're
not busy like pull up
so I hang up I told no doubt I'll be
there with you I hang up and then I'm
sitting at I'm just sitting in my living
room and I'm like you know what like I
saw it as an important moment for us as
a community you know what I'm saying I
saw it as as a as a
good moment to communicate to people how
blackballed we are in the industry
mainstream you know like Power 106 took
down the interview without even no
question you know what I'm saying like
it was quick um Adam for whatever reason
was motivated to put up that post you
know what I'm saying and then now
one of our elders that has a positive
voice in our community whether you
believe in what he says or not he's not
bringing nothing negative on the
community you know what I'm saying he's
not making our people look
um unruly or uneducated you know what
I'm saying so
when that was that question I just
thought to myself like you know what
this is a good opportunity for us to
show solidarity you know I mean Unity
you know what I'm saying because
everybody's always you had just I had
just heard whack one whack 100 all over
the place talking about how you know the
Southsiders ain't
um they don't have control their own
destiny you know they got to do what
they're told and we're like this [ __ ]
hit squad bro that that just follows a
dictator you know what I'm saying so um
I started reaching out to people
and then I called Gil like hey bro like
you wanna you feel like going deep and
he was like you know I think we should
right so I was like [ __ ] it so I reached
out to a gang of homies for different
hoods and not once did anybody
um asked me like hey who's gonna be
there or you know like who and it was
just because people felt the same way we
felt you know I'm saying like just
because we're not on IG or on YouTube
run our mouth about Brown lives matter
or or this and that or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it right doesn't mean
we don't have an opinion or feelings
about how we're being represented you
know what I'm saying
so I threw it out there to the homies
honestly I'm not going to take credit
for that [ __ ] like I might have invited
20. the other 80 came on their own
through Word of Mouth you feel what I'm
saying then people started calling me
and hey what's going on we'll pull up
you know what I'm saying if you see the
whole footage
um dog we didn't force our way in there
right [ __ ] ads been with me with like
50 cholos before by himself in the hood
you know what I'm saying so A.D was like
Kylie like come in you know what I mean
like come on let's all come in we all
here together because to A.D he don't
see a bunch of Mexican cholos he just
he's the homies yeah you know what I
mean those hey that's the squad both of
them come on you know you know it's so
interesting because I thought that the
interview you guys did was though
because it was at a time when I felt
like
the unity of black and brown people in
in Cali in La needed to be kind of
Illustrated yeah and I feel like you and
aed's conversation yeah but that's what
happens when when you get like two real
Street dudes I gotta be honest with you
like I had no idea like until maybe like
I've been out here since 2017 and um
I didn't understand like the I didn't I
wasn't raised out here so I don't know
the like the history between the black
and brown Community historically in La
is like a pretty divisive one yeah it is
because in Arizona where I'm from the
blacks and the Mexicans my whole life
have just been homies yeah you know I
grew up definitely yeah I grew up in a
heavily Mexican area all my best friends
are Black or Mexican and everybody
always got along yeah
um so you know I know that there was
like a few things that had kind of led
up to you guys during that interview and
um you know I felt like a necessary
moment to have with ad and you and you
know him and and uh you know I think I
think it it didn't to me it didn't feel
like to me it was a representation like
if look dog I don't just see things for
the layer that is presented to you you
know right I always see things in layers
I see things like from 110 to 2 tens to
three tens you know I mean everything
comes with fractions you know what I'm
saying and if you see the fractions of
that day bro like
it's clear as day you know I'm saying um
there's people that only give a [ __ ]
about views and ratings and there's
people that give a [ __ ] about The Human
Side you know there's people that are
currently living in a virtual world and
there's people that still live in
reality you feel I'm saying so but I
think it's important for like La I
believe
like a few other major cities are one of
the cities that can dictate how things
are presented and move forward you know
what I'm saying according to how we move
as a society other states follow you
feel what I'm saying so um I think that
mutual respect towards each other even
the way even from what I told Adam was
like look bro like just learn how we
move you know what I'm saying and then
you can move correctly and not worry
about 100 [ __ ] coming to your
spot and telling you what the [ __ ] you
did wrong even though it's common sense
you know what I'm saying but let's just
get like you could play with anybody
else don't play with us you know what
I'm saying like move how you want to
move with other people in other groups
or whatever but when it comes to like
what we represent like move carefully
dog because
we see things in different light you
know I'm saying what you might not think
is disrespectful to us is extremely and
what much and the opposite you know what
I'm saying so um it was a good day I
think it was dope um Adam wasn't there
which I to this day think is [ __ ] up
you know what I'm saying like him being
there would have just made it
um
more like transparent that that there is
no [ __ ] you feel I'm saying that
there wasn't no ill intentions right
there was no sabotage you know what I'm
saying
um you know how it is when you want to
defend yourself you got to get face you
know what I'm saying so I think that we
went there to get face and and A.D and
dunno's pulled up and it was cool but
like you know now it's becoming a point
where like it's a stabbing point though
like any little chance they get they
bring it up again you know or somebody
will bring it up or they're asking
Swifty about it and Swifty's talking
about well you ain't you know come on
bro like at the end of the day bro like
it's not about you or me you know what
I'm saying it's about the community the
streets and the [ __ ] that can happen
after we leave the studio and we go home
to our comfortable [ __ ] paths right
because most of us ain't posted on in
the on the Block no more like we used to
be right if we did we wouldn't have the
opportunities that we have so I think
that we have to hold ourselves
responsible for the people that we still
got on the Block you know what I mean